really nice to have you back here you're
doing so great it's good to have you
back on the show that's right you did
you'd stand up yeah over there so cold
as much more warmer come yeah I'm glad
you like it you did great you were says
I remembered you came here the first
time you came here is so funny yes the
first stand-up I did on TV and it was
great I loved it I'm so excited
I want to show all my family my mom and
my son who doesn't really care about
anything that I do but I tried to push
it on them and I find it's like hey come
on watch daddy on Conan I love Cohan you
love your daddy so watch it so so you
got him to watch you on TV that's great
yeah well yeah it seemed like it was
gonna be great but he was to let me know
who's in charge so he just got up looked
with me on the TV and I thought like he
was gonna have this nice moment he just
dropped his pants and then rubbed his
butt on the screen how old is he 32
[Applause]
I have to say you look like you're
taking care of yourself looks like you
you've dropped some weight are you
working out what are you doing thank you
for noticing yeah I've been working out
I've been eating healthier which sucks
oat milk and just straight-up suck it
well no one no one says hey I can't wait
til I eat my oatmeal no no but I mean I
just I was used to be so inventive I
would mix like kick cereal with Nutella
or like Burger King with McDonald's I
was just like a fire gherkin with
McDonald's wha a person with a problem
but now you're taking care of yourself
you can go I got sick I mean I don't
want to be sitting here sweating like I
am currently and I just got sick of my
doctors he's just a smug [ __ ] whatever
company yes he's a smug [ __ ] I said it
clearly cold he doesn't even take the
time to check anything just like oh I
know what the problem is you're
overweight I'm like yeah but I came to
you for a medical marijuana card
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'm not even sure you a doctor for real
your office is in the back of the school
bus
you